he's joins me now from Westminster thank
you very much indeed for being with us
why now why have you decided to leave
the Labour Party now well I've had to
make a decision because of the impending
general election and I had to ask myself
whether I'd be willing to ask people to
vote labour under jeremy corbyn's
leadership and i had to come to the very
sad conclusion as i couldn't do that and
that's why I've decided to leave the
Labour Party were you also facing D
selection I think there was a trigger
ballot coming up in your constituency
the the local party has been given
permission to go ahead with a ballot to
decide who they want to represent them
in the future but that official process
hadn't started three branches did try to
jump the gun by having no confidence
votes in me but they were told by the
regional Labour Party they couldn't go
ahead with that and what of your future
will you stand as an independent or join
another party and Sander the next
election or are you deciding you're not
going to stand well I really haven't
given any thought at all to what I might
do of the general election I've just
been agonizing over this very difficult
and traumatic decision but I will never
join another political party and I hope
that under a different leadership I can
return to the Labour Party which remains
my political home and are you saying
that Jeremy Corbyn is unfit to be Prime
Minister because of his failure to deal
with anti-semitism in the party or does
it go more widely than that
well labour can't be an anti-racist
party if it turns a blind eye to racism
towards Jewish people and Jeremy Corbyn
seems to have very great difficulty
recognizing that problem he thinks it's
confined to the right wing of politics
and national front of the British
National Party in groups of that sort he
can't see that it's there on the left
and since his leadership it's become
dominant within the labour party
so I think that that isn't a very great
concern it's not just about Jewish
people it's about the nature of our hill
society it's about diversity it's about
acceptance
it's about people feeling at ease within
society and that's why it matters to the
hill country and what do you believe it
is happening within the Labour Party in
its membership in terms of its attitude
to towards Jews things that people who
support Jeremy Corbyn almost a coke like
mama and just go along with whatever
he's saying and if he says that isn't
anti-semitism or there is very little
they just accept that without even
thinking about it I think there are
people who come from the hard left who
without realizing it have actually
accepted some very old anti-semitic
conspiracy theories about Jewish people
being all powerful controlling matters
acting in their own interests and hardly
recognise what they're doing and for
many other people really oblivious the
most of this they just go along with
what they see around them there are
people that are a people who do speak
out and I have people in my local party
who have consistently spoken out against
the anti-semitism they see around them
but often other people dismiss that as
simply smears against the leadership and
that's me as a horrendous thing to say
it's they're also a misogynist element
to this it seems that women MPs are
being targeted disproportionately there
is a misogynist element if you look at
what's happening and who was actually
being toileted and Luciana Berger my
friend and colleague has already been
hounded out of the labour party more
with hodge london long standing terrific
MP with a fine record is facing a
trigger ballot I am this Johnson in and
hole facing a trigger ballot as well
Ruth Smith so in the Labour Party Perth
has faced abuse and horrendous treatment
that this labor does seem to have a
problem with women
and just finally is this anti-semitism
problem really concentrated around the
labor party or are you worried it's much
more broad in British society there's
been a very worrying increase in
anti-semitism within British society as
a whole alone I'm indeed across Europe
which is extremely disturbing but when I
see this phenomena
rising in the Labor Party as well and
the leader of the Labour Party
struggling to accept it and then on top
of that the equalities and human rights
commission conducting the statutory
inquiry into whether the Labour Party is
institutionally anti-semitic I think
we're in a very bad place